during that visit for David Cameron and
President Obama also discussed the need
for new laws to deal with threat posed
by cyber terrorists well this map here
is quite extraordinary shows just a
fraction of the cyber attack that are
happening online right now as long as
like a meteor attack it's really quite
dramatic in deed well a little bit
earlier the senior vice president of
North that's the company that created
this map explained the scale of the
issue the north live attack map is a
depiction of attacks going on on the
internet all over the world in real time
it utilizes data collected from a
network of more than 8 million sensors
that we've deployed in 50 countries
around the world and what you're seeing
actually is just a tiny fraction of the
attacks happening in any given second we
sample
actually in our data stream well with me
is Mischa
Dola professor of wireless
communications at King's College in
London is great to have you here now
this is quite an extraordinary resource
in many ways but it tells us quite a lot
doesn't it about well the amount of tax
that are happening and also where
they're coming from where they're going
- what are we looking at here yes so you
see a pretty amazing map here which
shows us cyberattacks happening on this
planet in real time and what we see as
an example here some attack happening
originating in China and targeting a
computer in the United States it's
interesting isn't how we see clusters in
various countries as well and the
direction of travel of as well of these
attacks absolutely so you see in this
particular embodiment here a lot of
attacks originating in China and going
into the United States now we don't see
everything on this map really here so
probably we see a lot what's happening
in these 50 countries he is alluded to
where they have these sensors I presume
the majority of their five or eight
million sensors are actually in the
United States so we understand really
well you know where the attacks come
from into the United States but I'm not
sure we get a real picture of the whole
world so we have no ideas right now what
you see is actually a denial of service
attack many computers attacking a single
computer in system in the United States
it's quite impressive really here what's
which is the kind of attacks we've seen
in recent months they've hit some major
companies update and run so in France
the media has been brought down by
precisely an attack like that and you
know is this an accurate picture I mean
are we can we be confident that the
attacks originated where they say they
different ah good question rainy so in
fact the world is so digital today that
you could actually sit in the United
States pretend you'd having a computer
in China and launch the attack from
there back to the United States so that
we could do in theory today I'm not sure
how sophisticated their tools are to
deal with that type of attack but
because everything is connected the
days it's really difficult to draw
conclusions and all sorts of different
types of attacks we heard there about
the threat in terms of terrorism related
attacks but of course there's all sorts
of other ones as well whole list of
those what are the kind of things we are
looking at here so this map here shows
you beautifully essentially a statistics
on the attack of ridging attack targets
and down here and the on the on the
bottom right corner you got actually the
type of attacks happening and what you
can see there is essentially a computer
system trying to talk to a computer
system that is the majority of type of
attacks but there's another the is a KMP
attack here which is actually a tag on
the key exchange protocol so that's
going to the very root of the Internet
just brief if you will we had a from
President Obama and David Cameron today
but what can be done realistically oh
it's it's really difficult essentially
because the whole planet is literally
interconnected and we need to find a
really thin line between protection and
essentially our rights of not being
essentially monitored by governments and
there so maybe we need to do something
like we do with the airline industry we
are okay to be monitored our stuff to be
open when we go in an airplane but clear
in the street we wouldn't we wouldn't
agree to that
presto thank you thank you